so I'm Jan 11 I'm a physicist
most the time my day job and I also
write books and I work at Barnard in
Columbia in New York City I'm very
excited to be here actually I was a
philosophy major at one point in college
and then I had a physicist come visit
the classroom and started discussing
physics and I became completely enamored
of how powerful that wasn't how quiet
the philosophers cut so no offense to
philosophers I'm still very sympathetic
to philosophy but I did say over at
lunch when we were talking about this
that I'd be very excited to have some
deep sort of intuition falsified really
just by a philosophical argument I'm
open to that I don't feel I've had that
experience I've definitely had a deep
intuition falsified by a mathematical
argument and had to you know swallow
that bitter pill but I would I would be
very open to that I sometimes feel then
philosophical arguments I'm simply
sparked by something that already speaks
to something I believe and it helps me
frame it better but I would like to see
a bigger shift so I'm very excited to
hear from the compatible lists in
particular
you